ladies and gentlemen our guests Donald
Trump jr. what's going on man keeping
busy yeah it's been a while
there was no we didn't have anyone come
up and do anything they didn't tell us
how you're coming in all of a sudden
you're just here we figured the security
stuff but there was nothing yeah now
that you're the president's son there
was like for the last first of all I
don't know if you visited the men's room
but we're pretty sure and I don't know
if you've seen it Jim but like a day or
two ago they closed up the whole Sam
drilled I know it's really a bummer
[Laughter]
they added little rugs under the urinals
and citrus smelling like urinal cakes
and I was we were talking about it like
why would they just add this all of a
sudden and we're pretty sure it's
because they knew you were coming I'm
pretty sure that's not the cue no thanks
ah I'm gonna go with a hard no on that
one because they've been talking all
over they're like oh we don't know his
secret service gonna come is there gonna
be a security detail a week in advance a
day in advance of putting a rug under
urinals less than awesome idea they
wanted to kill from the hospital it is
pretty fancy yeah holding that smell I
thought the same thing I was like the
drips are just gonna be there forever
but they said no this is this is an
upscale move Roberts you wouldn't
understand I got your book yesterday
they sent me a digital copy I've only
read like 50 pages because it was
embargoed but it's really funny like
it's I was surprised I laughed out loud
on the plane and some of them it's like
it's sarcastic and every point you make
you whether people agree that or not
some I agree with some I didn't it was
still funny and it's like I don't know
how anybody is not gonna enjoy reading
this well that's I think that's the idea
is I you know I mean man you know better
than anyone frankly it was sort of the
today's outrage culture I mean your job
as a comedian and it's so limited in
terms of what you can say and I think I
just point out some of these things you
don't I mean like yeah I've known you
guys for a while coming back on back in
the oh and a days and stuff like that
and you know you used to be able to have
some fun and you just watch sort of the
restrictions coming on on what you can
and can't say I mean I still get
canceled on a daily basis for stuff that
I said with you guys uh-huh yep like I'm
I don't know like we were promoting a
reality show that doesn't mean that you
know that should be held against me in
the court of you know public opinion for
the next
50 years when we're obviously joking
around having a good time and it really
is funny I think I think your dad Trump
becoming president kind of sent a
shockwave through the canceled culture
kind of way of thinking because there
was all this tape and there was all
these like you know quote-unquote
career-ending horrible mistakes you
could never come back from and it was
like we got him here we got him here we
got him here and then when he wins the
election they go wait that's not how
this is supposed to work well I think
it's twofold I mean I you know first of
all yes I think the average guy is sort
of sick of this stuff I mean Chappelle
did a sort of a good job calling it out
you know recently and and some of these
things but like some of his greatest
skits like you know I can't even say
what they are oh my god and by the way
they were on cable yeah it wasn't that
long to thousands whatever when I was in
college like were some of the funniest
things ever but like if you did that
today it'd be it'd be over the opening
sketch where he played the black
Klansmen not they did the black white
supremacists was one of the funniest
things I've ever seen in my life yeah
and you could never do it now you could
never even contemplate it and so I think
people were sick of it but more
importantly I think my father also
handled you know deep and I say outrage
and sort of air quotes right he handled
it differently and that he didn't just
go Oh Mike I'm so sorry oh I'll never
it's like give me a break and it moves
on and I think you know the guys that do
end up sort of getting canceled are the
guys that just start profusely
apologizing because the reality is you
know and again regardless of for the
political spectrum it seems like the
people pushing that outrage filter there
it's never enough right apology is never
real even if it is the you can never
repent enough to get back in their good
graces and it goes across you know the
entire spectrum I mean one of the
examples I do use in the book it's like
sort of the Martina Navratilova you know
the tennis player like this is someone
we knew growing up I cuz you had a
similar story to my mother escaping
communist Czechoslovakia and stuff like
that and you know she came out a few
weeks ago against like the trans women
in female sports right
I've been pretty vocal about and it's
one of the few things I can put on
Twitter and people are like crap you
know I I hate Don's you you I hate but
I'm with him on this one I can't believe
I'm agreeing with him on something what
do you say about it what well I I just
say it's a little bit ridiculous you
know as the father of girls who are
athletic girls sports as if you know
someone who's watched sort of the
movement of you know title 9 and
everything that's like just to totally
negate it because it'd be one thing if
there were you know trans men dominating
men's sports but it's really only
working one by the way that was insanity
so I get out and I'm not afraid to sort
of call it out this is a woman who was
one of the great female athletes of all
time she was also like literally leading
the charge for the LGBT community for 40
years I mean you know she's a lesbian
very active in this thing she was you
know a proponent for those things you
know 35 years before it was cool you
know and when she said that her own side
just literally tried to destroy her to
cancel her to this so much so I mean she
had to start walking it back now this is
a woman who was a professional athlete
she gets it she understands the
differences and was like I don't know I
just I don't necessarily think this is
fair or right and she gets so destroyed
that she has to walk it back jeopardised
forty years of being an activist for
these things and then like three weeks
later she has to start coming out and
hitting Trump because that's the only
way to get back in their good graces
right well that is so insane the point
you made to about you know because as a
fan of the trans community which I
certainly am but you are right about the
athletics because it you do our know
trans men dominating male sports I mean
like male muscle structure bone
structure you can't they're a biological
school like there's not even this sort
of testosterone requirement right it's
you know it's it's not right and again
dude I'm from New York like I've plenty
of gay friends i I could care less like
I'm like the most live-and-let-live
conservative there is but there are
limitations and that's the point is that
you can never be woken up you can never
you know you can be totally accepting I
mean I could care less how someone
identifies makes absolutely no
difference to me for me happy people are
productive people productive people move
society forward but it's
well now we need to take the next chunk
now we need to take that next but now we
got to take it further and there never
seems to be an end did you see what a
President Obama just said about canceled
cultures it's really interesting it's
very similar to what you're saying where
do you think of and is bad but he said
like you know you have to understand
like there are people who might say
something here that doesn't take away
from like you were saying 40 years
correct and what they were doing tonight
I appreciate you know the point that he
made I appreciate the point that Ellen
made you know two weeks ago or as like
you tell me who I can Kanak right right
you know now I'm not gonna say that
those people also weren't perhaps people
throwing some fuel on the fire
throughout the years I mean I think we
can say that but that's the point you
can take it to a certain level but then
the culture is to just just keep going I
mean like I said the goalposts never
seem to stop moving to justify whatever
it is is there a part of you that when
you hear Obama say that you go oh this
is refreshing me it is yeah you know I
wish it woulda probably happened years
ago as opposed to you know now when you
know what we've hit a point where it's
just it's crazy and like I said I you
know I'm from New York City I have
plenty of liberal friends I'm friendly
of this and again I'll take the
political side because you know sort of
the nature of my life these days but
like I used to be able to argue a lot of
their points and a lot of when I see the
debates when I see the liberal debates I
mean they literally spent more time
talking about Donald Trump's Twitter
account last time and like essentially
eliminate the President of the United
States you know free speech then they
did addressing China like that's a
problem guys like this is you know I say
this I travel the country and you know
because of my hobbies and everything
like that I sort of have a pretty good
you know understanding of middle America
understanding the full irony that I am
still the son of a billionaire from New
York City so I have to say that you know
today I'm not allowed to have an opinion
I'm certainly not allowed to state that
opinion I can't state it aggressively
because that you know I would be
canceled
like I think we get it and you know I
try to talk about it a lot in the book
which is you know again I had a mother
that escaped communism right you know I
grew up spending summers with my
grandfather was a blue-collar
electrician from communist
Czechoslovakia in Czechoslovakia he sort
of had that convo with my father and
just said what you have here in this
country is incredible you have to see
the other side it's why I I've waited in
those bread lines that everyone thinks
are so wonderful like not not so great
like so you know for me I've become much
more you know active in this as I see
sort of that that trend toward where's
your socialism comes it's like it's like
a mainstream thing on the other side
it's no longer a fringe element it's
actually you know a party platform
almost and I still have you know my 93
year old grandmother you know who's not
exactly a normal 93 year old grandmother
from the US I mean this is a woman who
spent her early 20s hiding in the
basement of her farmhouse for two years
from the Nazis you know then lived under
communist occupation and show she'll
call me and we're having this
conversation she sees CNN you know over
there in in you know what's now the
Czech Republic because that's all they
get it's like you've done you don't
understand like it always sounds so good
on paper in all everything's great
everything's for free everything says
you don't under and this is a woman
again who's been through a lot right in
her life and you know has real life
experiences and she's sitting there on
the phone in tears for fear like of me
being her grandchildren and her you know
living under that says my kids her
great-grandchildren living under that
system because she's like I you know
been there you know we were sold this
bill of goods before it never works that
way that never stops what do you think
there's a realistic threat that we would
ever not be a capitalist country III see
I see the attacks I see it being
normalized and that's I think her point
which is it always starts off here I
said this slippery slope never seems to
stop you know when you see sort of the
indoctrination and academia from a young
age I mean I see it with you know my you
know kids in school and you know what
what they're being pushed and what
they're being taught and I always said
and when I'm out there even speaking
about you know that system versus ours
or you know I say you know what's
interesting
the Democrats they could get some people
just talk about some pretty amazing how
come there's not one person and it may
be you know one Jim but name one person
who's lived lived under those systems
meaning name one person from former like
Eastern Bloc Europe one person from
today's Communist China like bring it
closer to home like one person from
Venezuela it was like no no no let's
bring that [ __ ] here right it's only the
idea idealizing than the free stuff for
the idea free stuff
no one who's actually lived under these
systems is here saying no no we need
that here anything that it's only in
theory if anything those people no no
like my grandmother their sing you know
go to southern Florida speak to some
people from Venezuela right like hey you
know you went there in Florida by the
way boats only go one way guys you know
right I want to ask you to your dad is a
very a really bad relationship with the
press back and forth yeah what point
what do you think was that
like the point of no return for that
like what happened where it was like
this is never gonna turn around this is
only going to be a fight even [ __ ]
times had some moments of calmness with
them or this this seems like this is
never going to change what do you think
was returning play honestly I think it's
just in in accumulation right when you
see you know don't forget the mainstream
press that gave him a lot of press early
on because not because they liked him
they gave him a lot of attention because
they thought he'd be the easiest one for
Hillary to win you know to be like a
nice if like the great some good
material for sure but like you know that
was the that was the genesis of it and
then you could see sort of just the
one-sided attacks and honestly the
mainstream media has done themselves the
biggest disservice I mean you know I
talk about it a lot in the book but I
feel like I could write three more
volumes just everyday I mean just look
at this weekend right The Washington
Post right you know democracy dies in
darkness yep yeah [ __ ] al-baghdadi
the leader of Isis a guy that's
literally burned journalists alive a guy
that's thrown homosexuals off of
buildings a guy that's killed women
Christian missionaries who's
literally led Isis for decades he is and
I quote an austere religious scholar who
just liked watching soccer but a kid
like mix an Minh right who's a 15 year
old kid the Covington Catholic kid right
15 year old kid who's he the kid that
was yelling at the protest is his third
he did he didn't do anything oh yeah
yeah the staring confess we're talking
about the same kid he stood there but he
had the audacity of being a white kid
whose Christian when I'm at Kentucky and
a mother hat which is like the holy
grail of left wit like we got him they
needed to destroy this kid so that kids
a quote-unquote homegrown terrorist
mm-hmm for standing his ground against a
guy getting in his face who's a in a
stolen valor you know fake war veteran
like that guys a homegrown so it just it
never ends man so you've been trying so
hard to backfill the narrative that they
want and honestly I think they're doing
a disservice frankly I think they're
making my job easier when people like
well what's the most compelling things I
just listen to the other side right just
listen to what they're trying to do I
mean imagine I just imagine any
reasonable person in this day and age in
America or any other time prior to that
in this country where they'd be willing
to destroy a 15 year old kid for their
political objective you know look at
what they did to Cavanaugh right I mean
obviously the guy is such a serial
rapist that the second he got confirmed
we don't hear about those things anymore
now you see the you know the women who
come well it wasn't really true yeah no
[ __ ] was it wasn't really true but the
media heard what they wanted to hear and
they just decided to run with it because
they don't even have the pretense of
being objective anymore they are just
the marketing wing of the Democrat Party
is that the 24-hour news cycle that all
of a sudden they became so click beta
[ __ ] everybody has to get a story first
to get it for but it really does seem
like they're they're not even pretending
to not like everyone knows Fox leans
conservative and the rest of the press
leans people are criticizing when they
they gave up a thing about your father
they said Trump mentions peace or
something the New York Times put the
headline they actually changed the
headline because it wasn't anti-trump
enough and people
threatening to cancel the paper well and
that's the point and I think you're
right I think it's it has to do with a
news cycle I listen I don't think it's
any secret that mainstream media has
been left-leaning
just like academia has been left-leaning
for a long time but they've they've
eliminated the notion of you know
objectivity as a pretense I mean
honestly like just go to yesterday like
my father put up the meme of the dog
like it's literally a joke me yeah and
the New York Times goes there fact
checking it to see if this was real I
mean I'm like I'm sitting there being
like you can literally see where it was
like cut and paste in Photoshop but they
have to go out there and do this to try
to be like oh we got you it's like
that's like it wasn't serious I mean
have there been times where and like
life is obviously changed and I think
that this is why your family situation
is so unique because there have been
very few presidents that were such
public figures before this so like your
dad was on Twitter way before he was
president your dad I mean this is this
has been something that he's been doing
you are a public figure were you before
any of this like you've been a public
figure your entire adult life have there
been any tweets that your dad has put
out where you're like dad you're the
president now I'm not even saying you're
wrong but maybe we don't tweet this like
this any I've never been asked that
question so of course yeah and just like
I've gotten the call okay this is the
White House operator the president would
like to speak to you you're getting a
little hot really sort of realize I was
probably a lot more like my father than
I ever thought
we're when your dad causing those luck
you got to slow down on Twitter yeah
yeah without question but you know the
reality is you know hey all in all I
think he needed to do it because it's
the only way to sort of bypass you know
that filter mm-hmm yeah again I saw it
you know during the campaign I you know
I'd go out you know in 16 I was like you
know I usually did my own thing cause
like honestly the only place it doesn't
make sense for me to be is like wherever
he is he sort of commands up
presents like I'm just totally
superfluous at that point it doesn't
really add much value but you know for
some of those things I'd be there you
know then you see the mainstream media
headline it's Donald Trump said this
like a win like well yesterday and
Michigan ago where you know at the rally
at XYZ I think like well I was there
well well you know if you take minute
number one I need to take a sentence
from here and you take minute number 15
then you add in sort of what he's
talking about a minute number 37 and you
you forget everything else that he spoke
about in between and the context yeah he
said all of those words just not with
that intention not in that order and I
mean I saw it happen so many times that
it was like wow like I said I knew there
was bias before hey it's not like we're
you know immune to controversy he's had
more press in New York than any you know
my god any guy before him like you know
we did it with The Apprentice I mean hey
just with you guys alone like how many
times do they try to own me for things
I'm saying on like literally you know a
shock jock this show we never thought
we'd see you again we're happy about
like I said our approach is different we
don't then just you know crawl up into a
corner and die which is what the other
side would love you to do they want to
be able to own you and it's over and you
have no career like we're like yeah I
said it like wearily it's like let's do
it again
how much I should how much of it is
business to like the NBA reaction to
China with the the tweet about China and
then LeBron backing up going well
there's consequences to free speech like
with other social issues they don't seem
to mind yeah is there non reaction and
they're backing up is it cowardice or is
it a smart business move or is it kind
of it's a combination of both like if
LeBron said hey I'm not gonna talk about
this because it's all about the money
I'd respect that right but to talk you
know essentially [ __ ] about America for
a couple years now Steve Kerr same thing
he has a big you know all of a sudden
how about China oh well I'm not educated
enough on that one guys
it ain't quantum physics you know the
atrocities of the Chinese regime whether
it be you know the Muslim concentration
camps whether it be theft of RP like
this is not something you need to
educate yourselves on that much I mean
you have no
problem talking about an America where
you believe that your appeasing you know
your base your audience you're speaking
to you know woke culture you know that's
no problem but the psycho alright you
know I'm not informed enough to talk
about it like don't be a freakin coward
right at least own it and that's the
difference between Trump and all of
these guys you know they they hit he
owns it he says that that's what I said
a hundred percent in this say some about
Saudi Arabia which I actually liked even
though I hated the sentiment but I was
the most honest thing a politician ever
said about Saudi Arabia after the show
he he said look they they're buying 100
billion dollars worth of stuff like
there was an honesty in that that other
politicians will not use it's the same
reason the other politicians are doing
what they're doing they just have to be
able to go out there and pretend there's
another pretense I mean you know the
reality is you know he is a business guy
he's running this country and trying to
run this country like a business which
it should be instead of what we've seen
in the past which is a bunch of guys who
are nothing but politicians who have no
actual experience who've never signed
the front of a paycheck who've never had
people's livelihoods you know their
families well being dependent on their
success every day like my father has by
being a businessman and that's why you
get the results and by the way you're
getting those results despite despite
unprecedented incoming right I mean III
think we can say objectively that no
president prior to Trump has anything
like this in terms of sort of incoming
hatred whether you like him or not give
me a break
right and so he's doing those things in
you know all-time low unemployment for
african-americans that's not that did
just magically happen that's because of
policies that's because of eliminating
regulations that's because of the things
that he did that allowed business to
thrive which allowed people to get hired
all time low female unemployment
all-time high you know African American
startup businesses all-time high female
start-up businesses but like there's not
a single economic metric where we are
not better off today than we were three
years ago you don't hear it you don't
hear about it because you're getting it
and that's the problem and that's why
he's so vocal on Twitter and that's why
I'm so vocal because again when you look
at it through the filter of the media
you take those stats and you you
literally will talk about something that
is totally irrelevant
uh 95% negative coverage I've test 95%
negative coverage like that's hard to
overcome for me I live this stuff all
day long you know the average guy by the
way the average guy seeing five minutes
of me out well you know we fight that's
the difference yeah the average guys
seeing five minutes of news a day even
if his wages are going up which is also
happening for the first time in modern
history well maybe there's something
wrong there I mean that's the point I
mean they're literally trying to bias
and and control of an election I mean
I've spoken more about this frankly as
it relates to social media and this is
the other thing I really cover in the
book because you know I was the guy you
know yelling about this three years ago
the social media censorship and what
they've tried to do to me try to do with
my father and you know you could say
it's just it's literally a dry run setup
to try to minimize the actual message
from getting to people who want to hear
it you know when I was the most recent
one was what like two weeks ago and I
literally type in my Instagram handle
now I have two million followers on
Instagram and I share the name of the
President of the United States with like
15 and I'm typing in my name and we show
up on my page five of the scroll be up
behind like Don Trump three to 7qc a
shadow ban underscore seven with you
know two followers and one post like
come on guys this yeah this is Bill a
lot of comics have been talking about it
- they've been shadow yeah I think it's
a real thing
I have to ask you something mm-hmm we
were talking about it on the show
recently you've been very close to you I
mean you've been in the White House but
you're very close to the White House as
the son of the president do you think
there's a possibility that the United
States government is covering up the
existence of extraterrestrial life it's
the question I wanted to ask my father
for a very long time
I think there's aliens being covered up
I've wanted to ask I'm almost too
embarrassed to ask is it really serious
like if you get one question like it's
probably the question but I'm sort of
embarrassed admitting that you know so I
don't know maybe you do it like casually
you go ours on this radio show and this
is a mess like do anything aliens exist
I mean is a stupid question what do we
think
yeah but do you think so or no you know
listen I would find it as a as a
believer in sort of math and statistics
even though that those two are
racist today well you've seen those
right I mean you know that is that is
what some are trying to convince is oh
hey I would find it hard to believe that
in a universe the size of ours and and
whatever is beyond that that there's not
something there I I don't I don't know
that there's some sort of massive
cover-up I don't know that I necessarily
believe that but I would find it hard to
believe that definitely some sort of
other life out there I feel like their
wool if there was a cover-up you would
have at least heard a whisper of it by
now no probably not
how about the JFK stuff he wanted a lot
of those documents unsealed like he did
certain things he wants this stuff out
in the public I think he did and he's on
but again no different than the other
stuff what they're trying to kill him
for there he's like okay here's the
transcript like you know we're not the
ones get conducting things okay when
they've spent two years trying to throw
me in jail for taking it on so here's
the a mess like what I literally put him
out on Twitter myself he did the same
thing with the transcript on the Ukraine
call like here you go never leave the
other side that's conducting these
things with one prosecutor one judge one
jury in the basement of Congress for 41
days and you know I hear about democracy
dying in darkness but I don't hear
anyone in the Washington Post
complaining about the way that's going
because they're getting the end result
and the narrative that they want again
so you know I think his general nature
is frankly to be to be pretty open and
out there and let the people decide but
that's not necessarily the way the
government has you know perform when
they come after you legally even if you
know you're not guilty even if you're
gonna put your emails out when they are
threatening to come after you legally is
there a part of you that's terrified
going like there are plenty of cases
where people have been innocent we're
people like the world knows it's it's a
great way this is another why don't know
if you got to this one in the book you
know but I talked about a lot because I
mean you know really no I was probably
the number two target of the you know
the Muller investigation right I mean
there were like oh we're gonna get him
now and I mean even my own lawyers like
you you can't be that vocal on Twitter
you can't attack these people they're
gonna be subpoena you I'm like you think
for one second like if I went out there
and was like the nicest guy in the world
to Adam Schiff like you think for one
second he's going
be any nicer to me like even at the lake
after three or your book hashtag full of
[ __ ] everytime is lasting millions of
dollars and I'm literally like they're
like they've actually come to me like
you know what you were right like like
you you get no points for being the nice
guy you get you so I think it's
interesting cuz I think it's sort of the
thing that Trump has taught other
conservatives which is like it's okay to
fight back like you don't just have to
take the loss because the other side
wants you to even when you're right and
so for for this process it was you know
it's sort of strange but I guess I got a
little bit of that Trump teen which is
like I'm just in the fight like I
whatever we're not gonna so I never
thought about it in those terms even
though I mean you can look at very real
result again I was a target you have
every minute he committed try like I
commit a treat for taking a photo like
it wasn't treason for Hillary to pay for
it operatives to go into these countries
and collect dirt to assemble the fake
you know dossier that we all know is no
disproven you had 19 you know robert
muller who was above reproach because
you know he was the head of the FBI and
a decorated veteran like I think even
even my liberal friends like they saw
him testify in about 30 seconds they're
like oh my god this guy's just a
figurehead like and I talked about this
in the book cause you could see you know
second question like mr. Muller have you
even read the Muller report that you
spent two years on and forty million
dollars like he didn't know who Fusion
GPS was and you realize like okay they
put him in there because he had a good
track record he was sort of above
reproach because of that record but like
he had no idea what was going on yeah he
was totally used I mean imagine
assembling a bipartisan legal team that
had 19 Hillary Clinton donors on it and
not a single conservative like the whole
thing was a sham and you knew it was
gonna be from day one but but that was
the nature of it and like I said I
probably I probably should have been
more concerned about it than I was but
honestly I didn't lose any sleep about
it cuz I knew I was right I knew I was
gonna fight and I wasn't just gonna curl
up in a ball and die and again I think
that's probably you know genetically we
probably have a slightly underdeveloped
sense of self-preservation yeah but you
know that was you know my response and
like I said if you looked at me and my
dad you know in business before you know
everyone's like you know down sort of
the one that's not at all and I probably
wasn't whether my hobbies or what I did
you know it was you know backed into a
corner like that's when I was like oh
you know the sort of jeans kick in and
that's the way we handled it and I think
it worked out great what do you think
yeah like I think when Obama said he
wanted transparency I think he meant it
when he said it and I think all of a
sudden the system he gets in and he just
couldn't achieve it what do you think
once you finally get to the job he's the
president now he has the gig what do you
think is the the most surprising thing
for him that he's had to encounter that
he thought would be doable and isn't
doable or what has he encountered that
you think it's been a shocking for him
oh I won't speak for him but I think my
opinion looking as an outsider is sort
of the amount of people who want to work
in an administration only to try to be
subversive to it you don't mean huh you
know like if the way I sort of look at
it and what I've said you know and I'd
probably cover this in the book a little
bit this which is if you weren't a
conspiracy theorist sort of like you
know believer in the deep state prior to
2016 I probably understand that if
you're not now you're freaking [ __ ]
well speaking of conspiracy yeah do you
number one do you believe there is a
fake Melania and number two have you met
her you know not not not to my knowledge
if it's a fake Melania it's it's a very
good it's a very good representation but
that was the whole Vegas you know you
know you see the article Melania is
being held captive this is the crap that
we're dealing Bhama didn't get a
headlines like that there was no you
don't never accusations of a question it
was always Camelot it was regardless of
whatever is and whatever the truth is
like there was never you know so the
media went from literally being a
cheerleader we're even bad things were
perfect
- exactly the opposite and I think again
I think people do see the hypocrisy I
mean I think you can still be you know
left-wing and be like okay you know the
regardless of this I mean I see regular
people around the country they like
listen I may not necessarily love
everything but like let him do his job
you know and when you see again the
results and especially the results
relative to the incoming it's sort of
outstanding I mean like imagine they
could just the other side work with them
a little get us MCA passed right
the renegotiation of NAFTA NAFTA has
done nothing but [ __ ] send American jobs
abroad
it's literally allowed us to be are like
our only real export has been the
American dream we've said he managed him
to negotiate that again people said it
was impossible it's been sitting on her
desk for nine months she won't bring it
up because she knows even her people
would have to vote for it so it's that
sort of that mentality is hey it's good
for America it's good for our
constituency it's good for everyone but
we can't give Donald Trump even a
partial win right we can't on this thing
so we would rather watch Americans
suffer
then do something that's good for them
because it hurts Trump and I mean it's
that sort of mentality for me as an
American it's disgusting and it faces me
you can you explain George and Kelly and
Conway to me I don't know
[ __ ] I respect the fact that your
father's kept her on and but her husband
I find hateable just because this is
your wife and you're just you think
you're just you're your she on some
level agree with him how do they stay
married I don't think so but uh you know
listen I'm not gonna apply on people's
individual relationships but again
imagine imagine the husband of a
high-ranking left-leaning official was
doing that they destroy him
right you know this would be the second
I met you know he's bitter he didn't get
a job in the administration that he
wanted she did she's now the rock star
that's out there you know doing a good
job and he's pissed but like you know
where are the feminists like attacking
him no no well he's attacking Trump so
he gets a total pass on the fact that
he's making it really tough for her to
be able to do her actual job that she
signed on for you know this is a grown
woman that's deciding to do this and
she's good at it so again it's one of
those things like now this guy's the
hero because he's part of the resistance
I mean give me a break right I can't
believe it when I see it like whether or
not they like you know James Carville
and his wife would they both in our
opposite ends of the spectrum is a
liberal and a republic they're publicly
and he's like so publicly against the
man that her job is to publicly support
I mean we talk about it all the time
it's the craziest thing I've ever seen
yeah no I'm with you on that one when do
you think because you talk about speech
and this book is again it's what I've
read of it it's very funny and it's even
stuff I didn't agree with I like you you
back up your points very well so I know
exactly why he feels the way he feels so
if you think you don't agree with it you
should still it's a fun book to read and
you'll enjoy it
when did speech get away from even
George Carlin said this in an interview
he said the censorship is coming from
college campuses he's like I hate to say
it man when did the left lose their
their kind of grasp on speech being free
and that became then a conservative
strong point you know III don't know but
it's been going on for a while and like
I said it's a slippery slope and I think
just you know Trump is just like the
accelerant to all of that because again
you know I will go out there like like
my father
in 16 he's like he's got to be the
president for all Americans not just the
ones that you know he may politically
agree with and so I mean even for me
when I go out there I'll go speak on
college campuses I'll go do this and I
you know I can assure you there's
nothing quite so untolerable aren't you
know you can you can have well you know
whether it's the Martina thing whether
it's like you can be with someone
literally ninety-nine percent of the way
but if you're not that last one percent
like you get no credit for any of it
and so you know it's been a slippery
slope for a while I mean again I you
know I went to an Ivy League school and
from New York City I have plenty of
friends that are from you know from the
left side I used to be able to put
myself in their shoes and I think
hopefully that comes across in the book
which is like we can have dialogue you
don't have to agree to be able to have a
respectful conversation I mean I used to
be able to put myself in a lot of those
you know left-leaning positions and
argue I'm almost for sport I may not
necessarily agree with them but to do
that you're not even allowed to have
those conversations now you're not
allowed to you know give someone a
plaque for him to speak there you know
other views I've spoken to college
campus a few weeks ago I mean max I
didn't know whether to be upset or
impressed there was you know a young
lady in the back that literally went
like 45 minutes straight like no I gotta
hire this person if you could channel
that energy into something productive
not like underwater basket-weaving
whatever they're learning in college
these days and like you know you know
that hate can be a powerful motivator
like you know we could do something with
this but clearly good at what she does
yes yet you know I'm not sure what that
is I'm not sure harm screaming I'm not
sure how to monetize that order to pay
off your college debt you know I'm
trying to figure that one out but like
you know how good are your opinions you
know and your beliefs if you're not even
willing to let other people hear an
alternate viewpoint well make up your
own mind you know you know I'm not there
to say this is the only way to believe
who knows make you know maybe I'm wrong
on some of these things and the reality
is both sides are probably wrong on some
things for an ideal and an ideal place
I'm and I think people are generally
pretty happy you know in in the middle
and you know you know while I've been
paying
did all right and all that kind of stuff
I honestly I'm pretty you know on a lot
of social issues I'm pretty sort of
easygoing I could care less you know and
they don't they won't David that's the
problem I have with is they won't credit
them for anything like the the the
al-baghdadi killing that's a huge thing
that the leader of Isis was killed and
they just they can't even though if it
was botched and those soldiers had died
they didn't I'm an incompetent like the
way they did Jimmy Carter so the fact is
it was killed on his watch so he should
get the credit for it and then they got
the number-two guy the next day they
don't talk about that and and honestly
more important I think that the great
juxtaposition and I cuz I remember at
least people in the conservative side
you know I remember when Obama when he
got bin Laden it was I
III I mean my father goes in there I'd
like to credit the Joint Chiefs of Staff
the CIA for all of their work obviously
the soldiers on the ground you know from
Delta and the Rangers in new you know he
credited the dog he credited the dog the
k-9 unit you know in the speech to the
public and then magically the soundbite
becomes it was all about Trump I go did
you actually watch it like you know it'd
be one thing if you know no one saw it
and you're able to sell that thing but
like literally this was a national
address that he did he then gave up
about 45-minute hour-long press
conference answered all of these
questions gave all the credit really to
the guys on the ground getting these
things done and like the press will
store it was your typical trumpet it was
all about him I was like are you
watching the same thing that I'm
watching or is it just a convenience
down well they did the same thing to
with with kim jeong-hoon
whereas if obama had met with kim
jeongmin they'd be saying what a great
diplomat he's kind of broken this
barrier a little bit but because it's
trump they like that's a photo-op
yeah that's like for whatever reason he
still pulled something off that nobody
has been able to pull all right this is
the big part of my book you know we can
talk about economic wins that makes
sense for the business guy from new york
to be able to have those but like that's
a foreign policy win Jim if I have
another morning where I have to watch
you know some guy
Trump's doing it all wrong in North
Korea and I know because I've been
leading the US delegation I go wait a
minute you've been leading the US
delegation for how long well now for
about forty years ago you've been
leading this is your life's work you
know you were a career diplomat who's
been leading the US delegation as it
relates to North Korea you've never
even met the other guy you've like why
should we just believe that you know
what's actually going on when for 40
years you've achieved literally nothing
you know I don't mean to knock that is a
you know career public servant that's
great but like it's Einstein's
definition of insanity you know do the
same thing over and over and over and
expect a different result like the
reality is we made no progress
now we actually have a line my father's
not in IE he doesn't believe that
there's guys a wonderful human being he
doesn't but you know it's isn't it
better to have a direct line if the crap
hits the fan one day isn't it better to
be able to pick up the phone rather than
having to go through 15 layers of you
know and so whether we like it or not
it's actual real progress and do not
even talk about that you know Obama's a
hero because remember you know the
picture of him like looking at
binoculars at the DMZ from 10 miles away
like hey my father had the guts to go
there and meet him face to face before
we before we wrap because we got to get
you onto your hands and everything
you're very busy guy here's what I need
to know yeah aliens right we're going
back to this our only no I I got you the
aliens I'm good we're done one milania
we got we got that yeah that do you
really think Epstein killed himself
it's funny because this is one of those
things you know if whatever I say it's a
lose right yeah but a man there's a lot
of coincidence there yeah you know what
I've seen you know I'm not gonna say yes
or no but you know a guy who's there
he's magically then you know within
hours of being you know off of suicide
watch the two cameras that are on him
happened to go out the two guards just
happen man it seems like a lot of
coincidence you know that they try to
make Epstein you know they tried to make
it about Trump they don't talk about
like the 45 times you know Clinton's at
the island with him with you know they
say well he meant Trump at a cocktail
party one time look we got you I'm like
dad literally he was literally thrown
out of mar-a-lago because you know some
of the rumors and all this stuff so you
know and that's the problem the news
cycle whether it's that whether it's you
know Ukraine like I've been talking like
go look at my stump speech it's like
I've been talking about Ukraine and the
corruption there and all that nonsense
for like a year you know when it got
mainstream media pick up when they could
make it about Trump
you know Epstein it's been a pro
for a long time this has been like a de
facto thing whether you know Matt Lauer
at NBC all these things are do they've
been in the room when you can somehow
try to make it about Trump or when
they're no longer in power to be able to
do do your bidding you know that's
that's when it becomes news and so you
know they don't talk about those things
they only become news when you can
somehow use it as a way to own Trump and
we got them and so you know it's a
problem and I think we you know
hopefully we get past that hopefully you
know and again I think it's sort of
backfiring to regular people in America
we're like okay guys like you know you
had me the first time with the hooks
this is now hoax version number 12 like
maybe you're just full of [ __ ] we think
returns around at all do you anything
your father can do do you think that
we'll get a portion of the press to at
least kind of give him some credit for
something is there anything no he'll
never get credit but I mean I think the
way to handle this you know the only
cure for Trump derangement syndrome is
four more years and I mean that you know
sort of funding Lee but I also mean it
somewhat seriously in the sense that you
know the mainstream media didn't get
what happened in 2016 you know they're
still trying to figure you know the
three people I talked to in my room at
the New York Times like not one of them
would vote for Trump how did this happen
you know they still don't get you know
that mainstream America is you know sick
of sort of being left behind that you
know they're sick of being you know
pander to but never actually delivered
for and you know I think that's
continuing because you know again I see
that and again I have to cough yet
anything I say to this point with yes I
am the son of a billionaire from New
York City I get that but between hunting
fishing competitive shooting out like I
spend a lot of time in the Midwest and
in Rust Belt I went to you know boarding
school in Pennsylvania from 12 to like
18 like you know it's a while that was
like you know rich kid boarding school
whatever it is like yeah the first girl
I ever dated was from a Rust Belt town
like I know these families I spent time
with them my formative years were there
so I think we have an unusually good
understanding of real America given that
on paper we probably shouldn't and you
know honestly I think those people are
sick of it and you know I think that
shows and will continue but again we're
not in a fair fight you know between
mainstream media between the messaging
that's out there between pop culture and
Hollywood have been it's not that easy
to get the message
down through those people bite by any
other standard 2020 should be over by
now but it's not because we're not in a
fair fight we're in an uphill battle so
you know we'll see what happens but uh I
think it would be one of the great
messages to actually getting back some
sort of sense of normalcy which is like
you guys got to stop this nonsense and
now the book is called triggered and
it's really good man again I wish I
would have gotten in a few days ago
because the first the fifty pages I read
on the plane were great it's out for
everybody on Tuesday by the way
November's day yeah and it's available
for pre-sale now it's Amazon it's on
Amazon so you can get it in a you know I
think there'd be nothing funnier than
triggering the left bringing it to
number I just want it to be number one
just so again just soak in laughs
because you know that would drive them
nuts and even if you're liberal you can
even disagree with a lot of the stuff it
says on speech I mean this stuff it
talks about speech and cancel culture
and the stuff I didn't agree with I
still liked how you addressed it and it
was still funny and you still addressed
it and gave you gave it a good reason as
to why you felt how you felt so if
someone doesn't agree with it well at
least you know why you're coming from
the place yeah I think I tried not to
take it you know there's places that you
could say take it further for the
outrage but I'm not looking for outrage
I'm actually looking to have a real
dialogue in that you know hopefully that
comes across one more Jim and Sam catch
up with full episodes and interviews
from celebrity guests anytime on demand
using the Sirius XM app
[Music]